hey chess friends national master james
canty iii here with chess.com and today
we have the top
five moves from lavon aronian let's get
right into it this first game is
actually levana ronin playing with the
black pieces
against ivan sokoloff in 2006.
let's see what's going on in this
position here so bishop takes b8 there's
obviously the bishop took a knight here
because the knight was sitting on ba
so you have an option of just taking it
back just try to keep material somewhat
even or
try to figure out this position you
could just capture back which is
white's expecting that and then maybe
we'll do something else while maybe
kicking or
and and highlighting the position that
white has
or black has with the weaknesses here
but aronian chose a different move here
in fact he chose
queen f6 very strong lots of prep still
here uh he's still in his home prep here
there's a lot going on with this knight
uh knight takes c3 pawn takes bishop
takes and of course we're skewering here
or
forking in a way but taking that rook on
a1 and you're done
not really but of course at the same
time he's trying to take this pretty
obvious threat so white says okay
i'm going to let you have it because i
am not going to
take it back i'm going to play something
in between
attack two pieces instead of one this is
a very brave move in fact we even
watched the move after black moves here
a3 hitting b4 and c3 at the same time
there's no like cool discoveries check
this out
where does the knight go to do anything
with this check and if you do anything
with this check i'm going to take
with b4 i'm going to take on b4 the
whole attention intention of a3
is to take on b4 when you move the
knight so of course that's attack
now instead of playing just really
passive defense
moving the bishop you always want to
look for active offense the best defense
is always going to be offense so with
some offensive moves here
you have to kind of look around the
board maybe you're thinking moving the
knight somewhere but again that's going
to be answered with a takes b4
so levon chose bishop f5 develop at the
same time
get a piece into this attack and maybe
this queen goes somewhere weird and then
we'll have
like a knight v1 check maybe some all
kinds of things that can happen here
followed by queen takes b2
all kind of crazy stuff on the back
ranks and it looks wild
so of course so-called finds a nice move
here queen d2
saying go ahead move the bishop go ahead
move the knight move anything
i dare you to move the knight here
because i'm going to take here and if
you move the bishop i'm probably going
to play b4 which
that's exactly what happens bishop a5 b4
this is a standard move
that you make when you play e3 right a
play e3 play a3
you play b4 same thing over here
sometimes h3 and g4
so it makes sense to play b4 but in fact
it's not the best move
e3 would have actually kept on ivan
sokolov here in
the game steal but b4 was the option
natural move to make and i mean it
really is
just getting rid of this diagonal how
dangerous it was it was very annoying
and again instead of doing passive
defense we're going to do active offense
and the best defense
is offense so we're going to play 94
attacking the rook on a1 and the queen
at the same time
now sokoloff's like that's simple i
already saw that queen c1
i'm defending everything and you have to
move your bishop here
or do you it's black to move what do you
do here guys
what do you do what do you do after
queen to c1 after queen to c1 here it is
are you ready for this are you ready
would you think it is captures do you
think captures maybe maybe b6 that's
strange
what else would you do here maybe knight
takes g3 or
rook c8 and we grade what a move
sacrificing the bishop
and then rook takes c5 and we live and
this is getting ridiculous queen's
coming in
there's meeting every i mean there's all
kind of mates this is a family channel
so after rick the c8 there's rook to a2
getting off of this file or this
diagonal here doesn't want anything to
do with this anymore
the queen needs to move eventually and
we want to probably block here now again
it's your turn black to move erroneous
on the initiative here time and activity
we got pieces flowing we're active king
is uh undeveloped king is a really safe
and
on development is is very very big for
white here so black to move what do we
do guys black to move here it is here it
is you ready
and uh rook takes c5 oh my goodness
is getting crazy in here the queen is
hanging and this is still like there's
two pieces hanging
okay really one because you can't
actually take this rook dude to the pin
but the bishop is hanging but the
queen's hanging right now so queen a1
saying all right cool hey look we got to
get these off the board aronian you're
doing too much
yes flashy i like what you're doing
queen a1
okay cool let's just get him off the
board and erroneous says well
of course it's on you what did a rodian
do
in this position what would you do black
to move
here it is guys here it is right here
after queen a1 i mean i could capture
and aronian just says you know what
queen c6 i gotcha not taking that at all
queen to c6 what a move oh my goodness
hanginess
with check not just a hanging rook
sacrifice
that's even harder to do and it's hard
to face
and hard to ever fathom is doing it with
check
queen takes h8 is check now of course
that it actually didn't happen here and
what happens here in fact it runs into
the same
queen takes h8 you have king to d7 in
the game though on suckaloft chose uh
after queen c6 queen e5
check and then after king d8 allowing
the check
he didn't want to um he didn't want to
do king d7 because queen takes f5 was
was check as well he didn't want to
allow it so
that makes sense king d8 queen takes h8
and now
king to d7 threatening mate on the back
rank
wow one way to stop it or temporarily
engine move right would be check
or rook a1 and then you check and takes
and may wow
mind blowing from aronian and that was
that was number one
now let's move on to number two and here
we are
with move number two with levon aronian
this game is alexi shiroff
versus levon aronian in 2006. so we have
a ronin playing with the black pieces
here
let's actually see what he does so here
with the black pieces guys
check this out first off let's do an
overview what's going on
well we see that there's one two three
four
five six pawns for white and
three pawns for black whites up three
pawns
and he's about to queen and you have
your rook here and you're like oh this
is just
over right this just looks completely
over for black
no hope but maybe aronian might find
something here or something that may
shock you here
in fact it is black to move what do you
do in this position
what did aronian juice
here it is guys as a spectacular 100
percent
i know my end games type move here it is
right here
look at this move king e8 oh my goodness
is that
real that is real king e8 is a big boy
move
what sacrificing i mean this doesn't
make sense
he just takes the rook but it actually
makes a lot of sense after king takes
well
we lock him in in two ways to do it
either or works king f7 or king f8
and now you have of course the draw that
happens in these type of king upon in
games but
white's in zug's wing he also has moves
that he can make here
what happened so let's actually put this
on a boar h4 king f7 h5 can get paid
we just go back and forth oh and you're
now stuck to making
pawn moves now because this is not over
so in fact
d5 we can capture and b3
and then c4 and we just queen
insane mind blown i know i know
i understand i know wow now let's go
back in fact that didn't happen in the
game but that was
going to happen there in fact so it was
it was insane actually
so after the king e8 move there was king
to g6 so he backs up
and says okay i see you huh crafty very
crafty aronia i'm not going to take that
rook
says shiroff here can get fate okay cool
we're going to get a little close to you
because you don't have many moves right
so if you you can't go forward first off
now taking this loses actually i'm just
going to take and then
centralize and the rook's going to
gobble up the pawns and you're not fast
enough so h4 happens we need something
to do
so black realizes wait you don't have
that many moves okay cool we're going to
do this with our king
king e7 king g7 same situation
same move right king e8 king g6 and now
do you get the pattern
can you finish out what happened in
these next few moves so you get the
pattern now
are you able to understand the pattern
that's going on here
king f8 h5 where do we go
king e7 king g7 and
kinky 8 absolutely right look at that
pattern beautiful technique
king g6 king f8 h6 king e8 king f6
thank you 187 rook king to g6
rook f7 and after h7 you
think oh i just take the pawn i'll just
take the pawn yeah that's cool
but in fact you actually play this is so
cool
i mean this is one of the greatest
things i've ever seen in in-game right
here is rook f8
you just go rook f8 it's completely
winning and then okay what king g7 and
man i would it would hurt to be sitting
playing white to do this almost want to
retire after this this is king g7
rook h8 and you're winning unbelievable
the same technique over and over here
the nice little pattern recognition
kingy a king f8
king e7 king e8 just going back and
forth in the little circle
exhausting all of white's moves and now
when you sit in this situation of course
king takes runs into the same thing
you're zugged out thank you so much you
got to move something and i'm going to
just queen and win this game as well
beautiful there from aronian that was
number two
and now let's move on to number three
and here we are with
move number three from aronian here
now in this game aronian's playing white
versus his opponent
is gailfand this is back in 2013. now
let's actually see
what's going on we always take a stock
of what's going on first so we have one
two three four five six pawns for white
versus one two three four five pawns for
black
okay then we count the pieces so bishop
pair for black which is equal to a pawn
usually
so of course even though we're down upon
is black i mean these two bishops do
give us some compensation for it
so and it's also they're pretty good
bishops too as well this could be better
place but this one's a monster here
versus the bishop at night this one not
so good because of the pawns that are on
it or the pawns that are on the same
color of this bishop
the knight's extremely strong though and
there is um some tension here on the
file
on and it's white to move as well so
with that being said guys it is white to
move
how do you proceed here do you just
capture the rook maybe you could capture
and follow up at night to see
six but you are eroning erroneous so you
have to remember that if you're around
like
what are you going to do in this
position why to move
here it is here it is aronian says
bishop h6
and that move really matters by the way
bishop h6 check that's a big boy check
well of course we have to look at what
happens
if he captures it this why why would we
put it here and not show you
what happens if he captures it bishop
takes h6 rook takes c8
takes and knight takes f7 getting the
material back in a better position now
the knight is dominating his bishop
pretty gross in a way on how this bishop
has to kind of defend here
the knight is very mobile they can move
around very quickly and attack the weak
points in the position
and white can go on to win this game so
after bishop h6 gail pence says
i i don't want any part of it pardon it
i don't like this
like we're just going to go back so king
g8 he backs up goes home here
and now aronian says okay now this is a
different position from the starting one
because there's a bishop on h6 and the
king is now on g8 now in g7
so that makes a big difference when
small changes like this happen
maybe some of the same ideas you had
before might actually work well
let's see what he does rick takes ca bam
there it is takes
and now knight to c6 works
oh man look at that hitting d8 so of
course in the last sequence if the king
was on g7
97 wouldn't matter we could just go
bishop b6 and defend this pawn because
it is a double attack
but now that the king is on a g8 and not
the g7
97 is a big boy move and that's gg start
a new game
that's game over so beautiful move here
knight to c6 and bishop f6
sort of force saying hey you take
hopefully i can take especially after i
move my bishop
but in fact he actually plays b5 he just
says i'm going to commit my knight to c6
here
and aronian is soon going to convert
this extra pawn is what he's saying
bishop d7
g4 we're going to fast forward through
the moves g5 locking the bishop in
but only temporary h4 we take those and
g5
now we're anchored this bishop this
bishop has no squares but to go back
really
which is really really ugly so instead
we may have to capture
which is what gale fan does capture
capture and bishop d a
saying okay cool i know this is ugly for
me but i'm going to try to hold
bishopville king g2 in game 101 i mean
look at these passers over here we're
going to try to get a mobile
and work this thing but we do need to
bring the king into action it is the end
game
king g2 bishop c7 and king h3 and right
here gail penn just resigned he was like
it's what am i playing for right you
could play on of course and
prove for aronian hey you have to prove
it but it's just winning it's a winning
end game
gilfin understands that and he resigns
in this position that was number three
now let's go to number four and here we
are with
number four of the top moves for aronian
now roronian played white in this game
in 2016 versus his opponent
fabiano kirwana so definitely a beast
right
he always played beast what else do we
expect from eroni in here
white to move guys white to move check
this out maybe pause the video this is a
wild one
why to move what are you going to do
here it is this is what aronian shows if
we actually look at the same at the
position here before we give the move
let's see what's going on
the king is actually in a center kind of
a weak king in a way
but look at the counterpart i mean sort
of weak as well h6 like where did the
pawn go where did the g pawn go
so it's kind of uh in a double-edged
position where this rook could actually
help us out
and maybe we could get something going
against blacks a white king here says
black here
but it is white to move now there is
many good moves here or there are many
good moves here for white
but here is what white shows here in
fact one of the fun ones that's in
fashion and maybe you chose this one too
is queen g5
looks like a queen sack whoa
we can't he just take my queen well he
can but i'm gonna get it right back
with interest here in fact pretty cool
pawn takes rook c1 is coming the bishops
are active you have a rook file open
so much compensation here pretty cool
stuff but after queen g5 okay fabiano
didn't fall for the gimmicks he's
it's fabiano right so he's like all
right cool yeah that's a cool move queen
g5
bishop takes c3 first we're going to
eliminate this knight and actually make
sure that you have some structural
damage here before we trade queens
pawn takes then he actually takes on f2
look at that move
saying that hey if i'm going to take
your queen this almost looks like some
type of bullet chess game
where people just making moves just to
flag here queen takes f2
check and saying that hey you know you
can take my queen because i'm going to
take yours right back
and now yeah you're going to take with
check but i stepped my king so virtually
some of the same kind of
positions this would have went to but
the difference here is that fabi said
i'm going to mess up your structure look
how gross the structure looks in fact
not the prettiest structure here for
white but we do have two bishops and
then slightly open game especially if we
start trading
like c takes d5 and that's exactly what
aronian does to say hey i have bishops
bishop's like what class raise your hand
that's right open file open diagonals
and open files like the rooks do but
open diagonals and lines
so we like an open game okay so that's
the game we want c takes d5 e takes d5
even at the cost of activating our
opponent's bishop as well c4 look at
this open the game work on a file with a
smile here
the bishop's got the nice diagonal i
mean they're swiping the board here
and activity on the h file sheesh
there's a lot going on
c4 bishop to e6 defending the d5 pawn
and after takes takes you are not
winning this obviously
so he defends it and of course we have
some more moves here so let's actually
pass forward
bishop d3 rick hey takes takes and after
that e4 so attacking the bishop
also attacking c6 at the same time but
he has a nice in-between move remember
the best defense
is offense so knight to b4 attacking the
bishop you take mine i take yours and
with interest the game follows
after that but here we go rick h1 check
in between move hitting the king gotta
respond
king g8 and then we snap those pawn
takes with the threat
of bishop e5 looking crazy and this is a
past pawn
knight takes d3 bam king e3 whoa this
looks crazy
knight before bishop e5 there is mate on
the back rank here
so f6 has to be played to make some
looks for my king bishop takes f6
knight takes d5 with check king e4 he
takes again
we take rook c8 and this is a one in
game guys we have to we have the extra
passer here
the pawn is actually close enough for us
to make uh the classic king to g6
move with rook 87 checking and checking
here so this is a one in game here and
after king f5
rook check and uh actually black
resigned right here actually after the
check there was a resignation but
this this game's over and actually it
was so cool to see aronian
right here do queen to g5 very
nasty nasty movement with nasty
intentions and that was number four guys
so let's get on to the final move of
aronian today
and this one is number five and here we
are with number five
of the top five moves with a roni in
here where rooney is playing white he's
playing against vedic
let's see what happens in fact let's
take a stack of the position
white is uh has one two three four pawns
black has one two three four pawns
opposite color bishops so of course
it can be draw-ish but also in times
where attacking chances are possible
here
and for instance white attacking g7
tying the queen down to the defense here
leaves one of the pieces kind of just
out there to do whatever
so in these kind of positions they can
be double edged but this also could be
drawn depending on how you proceed here
this is why to move here and this is
aronian
so is right to move what do you do here
here it is guys this is what aronian
shows now yeah he's trying to overcome
the fact that i just have the opposite
color bishop thing what do we do about
this the queen can't move as much you do
have queen g5 check coming
that can just kind of trade off and this
could be drawn in a way so
what he says is you know what we're
going to limit
everything that you have and maximize
everything that i have
how can i do that with one move would
that help you let's actually see if you
can find it now
here it is here's the move b4
what b4 how many of you were actually
thinking b4
in this position what in the world is
this move
in fact it's an excellent move it's a
wonderful move and a spectacular move
all at the same time why if b4 well of
course for number one
now if queen g5 we now have a passer
working where if you remove the bishop
which is already terrible i get to take
on d3
a4 is probably going to follow and i'm
going to have some really good winning
chances as white
if queen g5 trying to trade the queens
now so secondly okay now i have this
pawn
trying to queen and your bishop's really
bad the queen's
still defending g7 so we can start
walking this one
so vedic says you know what i am not
going to allow that
did you just blunder like why would you
play b4 you know i can hop assad here
and he does a takes b3 and now
here's the intention behind the move why
to move here guys what do you do
here it is here it is bishop to b2 and
the black bishop
is not even a bishop anymore it can't i
mean where are you going like
what are you doing what's your plan ever
ever with this bishop right
it's absolutely terrible and now we have
an outsider and this is made as well
unbelievable this is a such a cool
tactic to see here and something that
you may be able to use
in your own games now after bishop to b2
there's h5 trying to do something
and you think we're taking this pawn
come on now he had to try it
you have to try but we know he's not
taking his pawn g5
lock it up and after g5 there's h4 okay
a uh we're pushing a4 kg8 a5 pass pawns
got to be pushed king h7 a6
you can't take it you can't do anything
a6 is on the board and after a6 he says
you know what bishop d1
whatever bro we got to get something
going here king takes and the reason for
this is to play d2
now you have to be careful yourself
because there's made on f7 this would be
fatal
or actually close to me checking and
you're getting made it soon
after a promotion with check to a queen
is game over so what he did here
is in fact you know and if king takes
there is a check here which is annoying
and he takes the bishop and he might be
cleaning before you are
depending on the checks kind of strange
like what is this how did he get this
here you can go very very wrong here
if you're not spotting all the ways to
simplify or liquidate things
like aronian found here with queen takes
g7 just get everything off the board
i have a winning pawn in game where you
can't catch me i can take this one too
and you can't queen any of their stuff
takes takes takes and take this first
this is very important
because we both will be able to queen if
i push the pawn here and he'll be able
to push as well not fun
so king takes d2 and right here black
resigned
this right here was awesome stuff from
the man himself lavonne
orronian and this was his top five moves
here from chess.com so i hope you
enjoyed today's video
i'm national master james canty the
third with chess.com and i'll see you
guys
on the next video
[Music]